so you agree on that doing animal
shouldn't be taken from the wild with a
year with a sound justification yes I
can't say that that um how that argument
works a lot of the public think that
zoos they return animals to the wild
they are protecting animals for the
future and their funding conservation
and while they all do do some of that
most of the animals in captivity are not
endangered so to me I still think Sue's
are a commercially commercial thing and
I do think they should be phased out
zoos do provide an enormous amount of
educational material for the public
whilst you're right that the most the
majority of zoo animals aren't
endangered that's not to say that won't
change in the future I am NOT saying
that animals should be taken from the
wild but I'm saying that I agree on that
do animal shouldn't be taken from the
wild I'm not saying from that that we
should just take all animals from the
wild so I miss worded that you know
there is four things lying zoos from the
wild with a with a sound justification
yes
for Elephants to be read in Thailand
they have to be captive elephants and I
don't think there's any excuse for
elephant to be captive having had some
extensive dialogue with people who work
with elephants in Thailand I'm not
convinced that there is any detriment to
it providing the training is carried out
in a humane manner we've seen it we've
probably all seen the horrible training
videos well we all we have yes but then
there are perfectly conscientious animal
trainers who work with elephants and
Asian elephants have been handled in
this way for millennia there is an
argument made by some biologists that
there actually should be classified as a
semi domesticated I have seen the
training videos and they are horrific
and I'm saying everyone trains our
elephants like that but that to me
there's just no place for captive
elephants
[Music]
see that one coming yep humans are still
a part of nature if that's wrong why is
it not wrong for a lion a bird of prey a
shark or any other predator to do what
it has to in order to survive I can't
say that that um how that argument works
wild animals killing prey species in the
wild is very different to human beings
killing captive animals to eat for meat
when we don't need to do that I also
think now especially in in our society
the needs that we have you don't have to
have meat to do that it does but I don't
think it should happen I think there are
alternatives now that need to be
invested in again a lot of a lot of
these arguments for me personally just
come back to the welfare of the
individual animal just speaking from my
own experience I'm able to still walk
because of animal testing I I could say
that I own my life to medical research
and I agree with you that there are
alternatives which should be explored
the incident that sticks in my mind I
believe it was penguins and I believe it
was one of david attenborough's recent
pieces the Penguins fell down a crevasse
and the crew intervened and they faced
some criticism for it
examples like that I think that you know
that is a perfectly legitimate behavior
I think if you've got the opportunity
and the and the ability and you can help
them then yes
my life revolves around the care of my
animals and I am driven by my passion
for keeping and working with animals
it's generated so much positivity in my
life and then also the use of them as
therapist and service animal that don't
think that can be disputed definitely
strongly agree it's been it's been
proven many times that they can reduce
stress lonely person who's got a dog
that can be their only link the mental
well-being of people I don't think can
be underestimated
[Music]
not the most strong agreements come on
I'm buying okay thank you for agreeing
to stay with
[Music]